hey guys this is another video requests
on premature Brett here so you got a few
great hair you look at it look at
yourself in the mirror and you're like
man I'm not that old you're scared
because you feel like you're looking
older than what you really are
right but what is the average age that
men go gray both occasions mostly go
green their mid-thirties Asians in their
late thirties and african-americans in
their mid 40s so the bad news is yes
most of us will have a lot of gray hair
in our 50s all right but a lot of us get
gray hair prematurely and you're
wondering like what can you do about it
well the bad news is it mostly depends
on your genes right but that being said
there's also a few external factors a
few things that you can control and
that's what I'm gonna talk about in this
video so let's not waste any more time
let's get right into the video I have a
dream hey this is your first time here
on my channel welcome i'm daniel
considered subscribing also clicking the
notification belt so you won't miss any
of the next videos i'm doing anything
about style grooming fitness and life
itself now to know how to prevent
premature gray hair you need to know
what causes it right so that you can
prevent it so i'm gonna tell you what
causes it and also how you can prevent
it so let's start with the first one
certain medical conditions yes the
certain medical conditions that causes
you to go right quicker conditions like
thyroid disease or certain rare
inherited tumor conditions also sin
autoimmune diseases like alopecia and
others so how do you handle that well
I'm not a doctor so I can't help you in
this one all I can say is go see a
doctor about this let's move on to the
next one
another cause of premature gray hair
might be because you don't have enough
vitamin b12 in your body this is a
bigger problem especially for a
vegetarian or you're a vegan because
plant foods don't have vitamin b12
unless they are fortified so there's two
ways you can get more vitamin b12 by
eating the right foods and also
supplements so what kind of foods
contains vitamin b12 beef liver and
clams are the best sources but you can
also eat food like fish meat poultry
eggs milk and other dairy products as
well you can also give it from
supplements like the vitamin b12
supplements from Jarrah
I've added it for you in the video
description so you can go and check it
out let's move on to the next one
stress now there's a lot of different
opinions on stress and what influence it
has on gray hair and I've done a lot of
research on this but I believe that
stress doesn't make your hair go gray
directly but it can cause the condition
for you to lose your hair three times
faster and when it grows back it can
grow back gray smoking now there's been
a lot of studies on smoking and it's
shown that guys are actually two and a
half times more likely to go gray faster
than guys who do not smoke listen very
carefully I'm not saying that you will
for sure go grey quicker I'm just saying
that it's two and a half times more
likely it's also interesting that
smoking can cause that grey hair to look
yellow you see that a lot so how do you
stop it stop smoking
so what can you do about the hair that's
already gray well it's only three things
actually
number one is you accepted your embrace
it number two you dye your hair right or
number three you shave it all off but
number two and three if you dye it or if
you shave it it's just gonna grow back
gray again right so for me I'm already
starting to have some gray hair here in
the sides and I can see it and I embrace
it I like it I accept it I think we
worry too much about scars and wrinkles
and gray hair because when you look at
your life wrinkles mean that you've left
gray hair means that you cared and scars
means that you lived if you liked the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video cheers
guys
[Music]
you